a code of ethics doesn't solve anything
it might be a guide but at the end of
the day individuals have to make their
own ethical decisions every time they
face a question and a quandary I've have
had editors who stood by me and defended
me when I pissed off somebody in the
company and I've also have editors who
come after me and said oh you can't do
that because it's gonna piss off
somebody and no code was gonna deal with
that I think that I've learned new
ethics in the blog world online that's
not to say that they're better that's
not to say that I reject the ethics of
journalism that I learned before I don't
I teach them but I've learned an ethic
of transparency online and my blog now I
tell you the stock I own or who I vote
for and all kinds of things things that
I wouldn't have done back in the days
when I was a full time reporter but I
think are very important now so I've
learned an ethic of transparency I've
learned a new ethic of the correction on
blogs if we make a mistake we don't
erase it we cross it out we fess up we
admit it was there and if we don't do
that very quickly we're gonna lose
credibility I've learned an ethic of
openness and collaboration when I'm
working on a story I'm working on an
idea I asked my readers to help me and
they are very generous if I just ask
those are new ethics that I've learned
online that I think old media can learn
from at the same time there are ethics
of the old world that live forever that
are immutable
fairness accuracy balance not
objectivity but I think those are things
that we can do a better job of helping
to teach from old media from our
experience